hi I'm Kira and I'm an animator you may
have seen me on our series draw I feel
like the human characters are gonna be
hard if there's human characters today
I'm gonna be drawing the same drawing in
three different mediums I'm gonna be
drawing Tom Nook the cute tanuki
landlord from Animal Crossing so the
post that I chose for Tom Nook is just
you know simple little one him sitting
down holding a bag of bells something
cute Tom Nook is a super fun character
to draw he's adorable
it makes me sad that like everyone makes
fun of him nowadays and everyone's like
oh he's just he's just after my money he
doesn't care about me but uh huh he's
yeah I think he's a good boy he's just
he's doing his job I'm gonna do a super
light sketch don't want it to show
through too much with the colored
pencils I'm a little more familiar with
drawing with colored pencils because I
used to use them a lot in college I like
the textures that you can get with
colored pencils it's pretty cool-looking
especially when you scan it in to your
computer it's pretty cool like probably
the biggest area of color is where I'm
gonna start I don't know you can start
however you want
[Music]
something that I forgot about colored
pencils it's like a workout to do it's
just like this constantly scramble
scribble scroll until you fill in the
space like it gives you like like a hand
cramp doing it you can see me struggle
as I go on I I definitely get slower so
it's nice about colored pencils as you
can do blending with them so for his
ears and nose I'm gonna take a darker
Brown and blend it in into a nice
gradient what's also cool about colored
pencils is you can kind of like run the
lighter color over the darker one to get
it into a more smooth fluid shading and
for those lovely blue eyes I'm gonna
feed them too I was really looking
forward to that part you want to make a
pop for areas that are colored white it
helps to add some like very subtle light
or purple shading just to add a bit of
uh you know dimension to it
[Music]
I'm also trying something that I haven't
really tried before because my my hues
are limited here I'm gonna use a black
to try shading things to just uh bring
out those dark shadows a bit more and
actually it worked pretty well I messed
up you can see I messed up I wasn't
thinking at all and I just straight-up
colored yellow over where his uh white
sleeve is supposed to be so tried to fix
it a bit with white but uh you know what
accidents happen you just gotta power
through and there he is
Tom Nook in colored pencil this is my
wheelhouse here digital drawing so we're
gonna be drawing in Photoshop digital
drawing this what I do for a living
nowadays everything's mostly digital
with animation you know still the same
principles as traditional drawing but
now you have an undo button again same
pose for Tom Nook but this time we've a
bit more Liberty with the sketch because
it's on the layer we can just turn down
the opacity instead of having to worry
about like erasing or making sure that
the lines are like really light so they
don't bleed so I'm using the clean as a
whistle brush from Kyle's mega pack in
Photoshop and I'm gonna use a relatively
thick line with want to make it look a
bit cartoony and instead of using that
harsh crisp black I went free kind of
greenish dark gray no gives like a it's
like easier on the eyes it's like softer
what's nice about digital is you can
really zoom in and just get in there and
put all those little those details that
you normally probably wouldn't be able
to get real clear and traditional
because you're not good at planning like
I am a technique that I like to do with
a lot of my cartoony drawings is I
like the general outline pretty like you
know thick and consistent but for things
like the the cuffs of the pants and the
shirt and all the little details like
inside the body wait for like a smaller
brush because I don't know it gives like
a nice hierarchy of line width and
shapes and it also provides a lot of
negative space which is really important
when you draw cartoons like you have to
think about the way that your shapes are
laying against each other so that
they're readable for the audience you're
seeing me redraw things multiple times
and hit that undo button again just the
process of getting things how I like
them inking usually takes the longest
for me because I'm like I got to get
these lines right you know before I
commit to the color it's nice about
digital color is you have access to like
literally every color ever what I like
to do is I like to open up the hue and
saturation sliders and play with it a
bit to try to get it to a you know
different hues see what I like see what
works so for the gradients on the nose
in the ears I switched to an airbrush
brush so that way we can just like
gently cascade into the base color you
can see me struggle with trying to
maintain a good balance of negative
space with theá-- that I mask yeah I
wanted to touch the sides of his head
too much went for like a nice muted soft
seafoam green curve the eyes then I'm
gonna add a bit of like a like an aqua
blue for the shading in the eyes
something I also recommend if you plan
to use colors that are not strictly like
black and white for whites I'm going for
a lighter like off yellowy off green
color it's very subtle but it adds a
world of difference it makes it less
of the year I didn't want to go for any
intense shading in this just like a you
know pretty mild cartoon cel-shaded look
for the Pink's of his ears I just wanted
to make sure that they stood out against
the brown because if you make them look
a little too similar in hue to the brown
underneath it it gets lost and here he
is digital Tom Nook definitely the
easiest for me to do again the most
familiar with it it's the one that I
work in most frequently so the
watercolors that I'm using are like I
don't really use traditional media as
much nowadays because animation is more
of a digital medium currently but you
know what we got to work with what we
got so I usually start off with a really
really rough sketch super light cuz when
we do the watercolors we don't want it
to bleed through also the paper I'm
using is cold press watercolor paper
really good paper I highly recommend it
so I got my palette here and I'm gonna
start mixing that classic nook Brown I'm
gonna add some white and probably orange
or something to get it that more warm
light past Le color you're gonna watch
as I make tons of mistakes and struggle
because no matter how old you are how
many years of artistic experience you
have you're always gonna make mistakes I
am a living proof of that I usually
don't use a lot of water because I'm
afraid of it running all over the canvas
and seeping into areas where I don't
want it to go so I'm gonna start by
filling in all of the
biggest spaces that need color so the
brown of Tom Nook and I'm gonna make
sure not to go over the spots where I
know I'm gonna use a different color
especially if the color is lighter than
the color I happen to be using water
colors are not as forgiving in terms of
being able to go over them because if
you get like a dark color into it really
light color it's gonna be real hard to
try to get that light color to a look
consistent again so like I said because
these tools are super cheap
it looks pretty streaky but it's okay
because any likeness we can fix by
letting the watercolors dry and then go
over them with a darker color I'm
personally of the opinion that you don't
need the most expensive most
high-quality art tools in order to make
good art like if you have a desire to
draw you're gonna find a way to do it
regardless of whether or not you have
the proper tools oh yes you can see how
I've already messed up I had forgot to
leave the ears uncolored so I had to use
the pink over the dark brown which you
can see the dark brown through that pink
but you know what we're just gonna keep
layering it up we kind of got a cool
shadow effect with that dark brown so
I'm happy accident despite the fact that
I'm a little stressed at how this isn't
coming out exactly how I'd like it to
watercolor is really relaxing because I
clearly was not satisfied with just the
water color alone I decided to take an
ink pen and ink all around the drawing
to give it like that nice tied together
cartoony look I don't know I think it's
just a exit pop a bit more looks a bit
more satisfying in my eyes
and there we go watercolor Tom Nook
honestly for all the struggle that I was
going through while painting this and
just the unsatisfaction at the
streakiness uh it came out pretty good
you can look at a drawing forever and
ever I'd be like this is stupid I hate
this but then like you take a break from
it or you just look at the full picture
and you're like you know what I did it
it's okay
I can draw it's okay thank you so much
for watching again I really hope that
this shows that no matter what artistic
medium you work in you can make the art
that you want to you should just do it
because it makes you happy
[Music]
you